when should professional athletes feel morally
obligated to put their careers their personal
safety and their own freedom on the line to speak
out about political injustice raised in turkey
anna's cantor freedom decided to use his fame
to speak out about the issues that matter most
he moved to the us when he was 17 for college and
was drafted by the utah jazz in 2011. it was a
chance encounter with a fan that inspired him to
take his activism to the next level while we are
dribbling a ball on the other side of the world
people are losing their loved ones in their lives
and losing their hopes freedom made headlines
earlier this year for criticizing the national
basketball association and its biggest stars for
their business relationships with china which has
been accused of violating the civil rights of
ethnic muslims known as the uyghurs and forcing
them into re-education camps in 2022 he was traded
from the boston celtics to the houston rockets and
then waved four days later reason caught up with
freedom to talk about his early childhood growing
up in turkey as a basketball prodigy calls
for his arrest and what's driving his activism
ns scanter freedom thank you so much for talking
to reason thank you for having me i appreciate
that i want to start out a little bit about your
background um i know you were born in zurich
and then you spent most of your early your
childhood teen in turkey and then you move to the
u.s so we'll just start with that you know tell
me the whole story that as far as you remember
well the reason i um you know born in switzerland
because my dad was doing his master in zurich
so i born there i literally stayed up for
nine months i wish i stayed longer um you
know then i moved back to turkey and i lived
in the east side of turkey the city called
and um there was many you know armenians
many kurds many turkish people and it was
you know a city that you know people were
from all over the world um you know i stayed
there till i was like 13 14 years old and just
because of basketball i moved to capital ankara
and i played basketball there for two years and it
was an amazing amazing experience and i literally
just the reason i started playing basketball
really because i wanted to be a soccer player
but i was too tall for it too slow for
it so that's why it didn't really work
so i moved to ankara to play basketball
then i moved to istanbul the you know
the biggest i guess the most famous city in
istanbul i don't want to say the biggest but
then you know i play basketball there
professionally for two and a half years
and uh just because of um my dad wanted me to you
know play basketball and go to school same time
and i when i played with us when i started playing
basketball my my dad promised me said i want you
to be a good student for being a good basketball
player you know he said he literally sent me to
america so i can go to school and play basketball
the same time so you said you uh played basketball
when you were 14 years old is that one how did
that happen how did basketball came to play well
it's not the first most famous sport in turkey
obviously if you're in europe or especially middle
east soccer is like number one sport um but you
know i was like i said again i was like well my
i'm the tallest one in my classroom and you know
my friends were telling me to play basketball and
and stuff so i was like you know what okay i'll
just give it a shot and i actually was better
than everyone else in my class at my school and
uh that year we won a championship in ankara and i
was like i think this is going to be my path from
now on and since then i've been playing basketball
so how did your family feel about you playing
basketball as a career oh they hated that they
literally especially my mom and because my dad is
a scientist and my mom is was a nurse and so they
were all about education they wanted me to go to
school then focus on nothing else just studying
all day till i made my first check and after that
they're like okay you play basketball from now on
i was the funniest thing but you know they
obviously in the beginning they were not
supportive at all and but i was like well
that's my dream you know but that doesn't
mean i'm not going to go to school you know
but i always like okay this school is number
one education because my dad was always telling me
it's like it's not guaranteed that you're going to
make it to mba even if you do then you're only
going to play this game until maybe like 34 35
which i had to quit at you know 30. um so they're
like well once you retire you want to be able to
have a job you know you don't you don't want to
just go home and watch tv all day so that's why
i um the school was always so important um so you
said you came to the us to study where did you so
i went to a prep school in simi valley california
you know i went there for one year then i took my
uh sat and then i signed with the university of
kentucky you know i went there for one year then
i got drafted in 2011 by utah jazz the third pick
yeah so you played for multiple teams right um
do you have a favorite team oh that's a tough
one um when you say i mean obviously all of them
was an nba team but if i had to pick one i guess
i'd go with the next because of the city because
of madison square garden because of the fans but i
mean the fans have been nice to me everywhere i go
but i will say because of the city i guess i'm
going with new york okay um so i'm going to kind
of go back to your visit to the us you said
in one of your interviews that you know your
the name freedom was inspired with was inspired
by a visit that you made to the us in 2009
where you were criticizing a presidential
candidate at the time and your friend warned
you that it was actually the other way okay
so in 2009 i was i was going to prep school
for the first time and i remember we had a really
like tough practice and after the practice we are
all sitting down in the locker room and we're all
just checking our phone and stuff obviously but
back then we all had like facebook you know so i
saw one of my teammates criticize the president
and i was like very scared for him i was
like dude what are you doing i immediately
turn around like dude like what are you doing and
he's like what happened i was like i saw your post
and he's like okay and i was like well you might
be in jail tomorrow and he started to laugh and he
was like this is not turkey this is america and
i was very confused i'm like what do you mean
and he he started to like explain to me about like
freedom of speech religion expression protest and
i still didn't get it i was like what
is this guy talking about because if you
if you did that in turkey you'll be in jail
the next day so i was very confused and uh and
then later on the more people i you know met and
started to you know talk and about all this stuff
they explained to me about you are not going
to be thrown in jails or your family won't
be tortured just because of you talk about
some of the problems are happening in america
and i was like wow this is so
beautiful i think you know after
i guess water and food i think freedom is like
the most important thing that human being can have
so i was like i want to make this part
of me i want to make that work part of me
put my put behind my jersey and make literally
just just inspire millions of kids out there so
you changed your name on did you change it because
you you get an option during your citizenship to
change your name and that's it was literally like
four or five months ago you know they some they
show me a paper and they're like would you like
to change your name would you want to add another
you know name or stuff i was like yeah i do so and
i made freedom my last name what was your reaction
it was amazing especially in our locker room you
know especially whenever i walk on the street now
not just in america but like europe and everywhere
else canada or you know even even in my city
you know that i play basketball for
so i was like whenever i walk outside
people started to you know scream freedom even
when i play basketball you know when i changed
my you know last name people were chanting freedom
freedom literally every arena i go so it was like
to me it was just very you know emotional at
the same time i was like well this is working
so um you became a us citizen is it i think
it was like i'm trying to think i think it
was in november november okay and you had
a problem in the past with your application
do you want to talk about why it was so
hard for you to become a u.s citizen oh well
so i started to talk about i'll tell you
the whole story i started to talk about
some of the problems that are happening
in turkey because unfortunately because of
erdogan's regime took over the office since
then there is no freedom of speech no freedom of
religion no freedom of expression or no freedom of
uh protest and my hope is from turkey and turkish
government is that first of all to free all the
political prisoners free all the innocent women
because you look at the numbers there are 17
000 innocent women with their babies with their
kids in the jail right now are getting tortured i
remember back in 2013 there was a big corruption
scandal happened and president erdogan and his
some of his family member was involved in it
and that was like the and after that scandal
after he got exposed he started to go around and
put innocent people in jail prosecutors lawyers
judges and police and some innocent people
and after that he started to go around and
started you know shut down media atlas magazines
newspaper tv channels and i was like this is
not acceptable and i'm going to say something
about it and as an uneducated mba player
you know i literally put a tweet out there
and uh because of the nba platform it became
a conversation and i was like wow even one
single tweet can affect this much from now and
i'm gonna start to pay attention about what's
what's going on in my country more and more so
i was like i remember my teammates or my friends
were going out going out to bars or clubs
or hanging out i was going back to my house
and started to study about you know what's going
on in my country in america the relationship
between america and turkey the the the things that
happen in middle east and i started to talk more
and um because then be a platform many of the you
know media athletes the new newspapers wanted to
give interview and write up for them and every
time i say something was becoming a conversation
and so the the things i talk about really bothered
the turkish government and and the the things that
i talk about affecting me and my family you know
my i remember you know my dad you know got fired
from his job my sister went to medical school for
six years until this day she still cannot find a
job i think the the saddest one was my little
brother because he wanted to be an nba player
like his big brother but because of the same
last name he was getting kicked out in every team
he was so young i couldn't explain it because he
was telling me he's like i'm the tallest one in
my team and or i'm the best player in our team
why am i getting you know kicked out they they
were getting affected so much they had to put a
statement out there and saying we are disoriented
and i remember going to practice that day it was
definitely one of the toughest day in my life
and uh turkish government didn't believe that they
sent police to my house in turkey and they raided
the whole house and they took every electronics
away because they wanted to see if i am still
in contact with my family or not so phones
computers laptops ipads they took all of them
and they couldn't find no evidence but they still
took my dad in jail for a while but we put so much
pressure from here turkey with politicians and
media they had to let them go and then after that
they invoked my passport and put my name on
interpol list so till this day i'm still count
as like a international criminal you know and then
when they invoke my passport obviously i didn't
have any passport and uh and i wasn't um american
citizen so i just had a green card so that's why i
because of my name was interpolates i couldn't
really travel anywhere outside of america so i
had to wait five six years to become a citizen
so when i got my uh passport i started to travel
so the the name freedom kind of carries you
know a dual meeting you're actually you did
gain big meaning so it's just it's not just
that name it's there are lots of emotions and
you know meanings behind that name um how's your
family back in turkey do you talk you still talk
you don't talk to your family good question well
i mean just because of my dad was in jail they're
really scared that it's going to come out there
because they listen everything all the phones
they track down ip numbers and they try to see
if they're still in contact with me or not so
if there is any kind of communication they'll
be all in jail so last time i saw my family
it was back in 2015. but my brother plays
basketball in poland and so i asked him how's
my family doing how's my mom i was my dad he
sent me pictures sometimes of them and stuff so
um that's the situation what was the last
time you talked to them do you remember
oh good question to be honest i can't
even remember it's been that long
so i want to talk a little bit you know can i
switch gears and talk about the nba uh you are
very passionate um about um a variety of human
rights civil liberties um i watch you talk about
you know multiple um tyrannies in the world
um but you did focus for a while on uighur
the uyghur issue in china and the treatment
that the chinese government is carrying towards
millions of people in china
um and that you know cost you
a lot yeah do you want to talk a little bit about
how did that all come about it's actually a very
crazy story so i remember just last summer
i was in a basketball camp in new york
and we had an amazing basketball camp and
after the basketball camp all the kids
and parents were lined up and was they were
getting pictures and autographs one by one
i remember i took a picture with this kid
and while i was taking a picture his parents
called me out front of everybody and said how can
you call yourself a human right activist when your
muslim brothers and sisters are getting tortured
and raped every day in concentration camps in
china and i'm still smiling for the picture and
i heard that i was so i was i was just shocked
i took a picture i turned around and i was
like i promise i'm going to get back to you
so i cancelled everything that day i went back
to my hotel and i started to study about what's
going on not just uighurs you know i started with
uyghurs but first of all the things i have read i
was like i cannot believe that i have not or no
one has said anything about this issue before
so i was like i'm going to do whatever
i can to speak up whatever it takes
so while i was studying for for the uyghurs i
called my manager i was like i need you to find me
a concentration camp survivor and he obviously
was very shocked what are you talking about
um because on internet you can't find all
kind of news good news bad news fake news
because you don't know which one is true
so i sit down he found me one actually the
the woman that he found you just interviewed
yeah theresa and i we interviewed her here
so i sit down and on a zoom and start to have
a conversation with her and i was like she was
telling me about all the tortures and gang graves
she was telling me about um for sterilization
abortion and how many people were actually inside
the numbers and how many people are getting killed
inside how are they brainwashed they she told
me about the organ harvesting and you know the
cameras are audience cameras and stuff so
i was like if a human being carries a heart
you know like you have to talk about it
it doesn't matter what do you what it cost
um so and then while i was studying that at the
end of our conversation i asked her okay what
can i do for you she said nothing i was like what
do you mean nothing she said well i'm in america
i'm here i'm safe but there are millions of people
in consultation camps right now are waiting for
your help help those people not me i was like whoa
and obviously if you look at the numbers just last
year more people watched nba games in china than
american population over 400 million and because
of the jersey sales and shoe sales and endorsement
deals that nba get and all the players get from
china is the most important market you see all the
players before the covet uh whenever the season
over before they go to vacation they were going to
china to organize some kind of a friendly game or
organize you know bask basketball camp or doing
some kind of thing with with china and obviously
they were getting so much attention they would
get you know getting so much money and they were
doing i guess lots of business in that country so
it's huge it's a billion dollars of you know deals
every year just because just from the the tv deals
and endorsement deals it's the craziest amount
of money that i have heard um they don't want to
lose that what made me so angry was two years ago
when we were all in nba bubble nba was the first
organization went out there and said we are a
social justice organization and all the players
went out there and said we are more than an
athlete we are a social justice warrior or we are
freedom fighters we are a human rights activist
and nba was put in all this logos blm logos
on the uh on the floor and put on all these
phrases which was controlled by the mba we
couldn't pick anything else behind our jersey
and we went out there and play and every
interview was about social justice i was like
this is amazing right this finally nba standing
up for something is bigger than basketball
two years later this happened i was like
someone has to expose this someone from the
inside has exposed this because they will only
care about the things until it affects their
money and it affects their business so i was
like okay because two years ago when daryl mori
tweeted about free hong kong the boston
celtics made me media unavailable for two weeks
i was like okay that happened and then two
years later i have seen that not one one
official from the nba did not stand next
to me i was like i'm going to expose this
you know and i want a lot there not one person
standing right next to me so that's crazy what
was the most controversial tweet you put out
there the ones that you got the most pushback on
i don't want to say controversial but the
most attention tweet that i have it was
about nike you know because it was the first
time ever and a player and an athlete called
uh a company nike you know um it is the biggest
sponsor of nba and i literally said that what
nike is doing is modern day slavery they stand
up for you know black lives matter in america
latino community no asian hate lgbtq community
but when it comes to china they remain silent
and i was like we have to expose this and i wanted
to do it in a very unique way you know because
when i was a kid whenever i watched an nba game
the first thing that i was watching was the shoes
what color they are what brand it is if it's
comfortable and i was going out there and buying
it you know so i wanted to do it in a very unique
way where i can put all these designs all these
abuses on a shoe and go out there and play because
i looked at it there's no rule against it in mba
a lot of people were put in you know
black lives matter brianna taylor i
can't breathe and all this phrases i was
like so there is no um rule against it so
we work with this you know artists who have been
oppressed by their governments and you know he
created the shoes you know free tibet free uighur
free china and you know you know all stop organ
harvesting and surveillance here so it was it was
getting so much attention i remember my first game
uh it was on espn madison square garden first
game the whole world was watching that game
so i was like i put the shoes on i went out
there and i started to warm up and all the
players were like looking at my shoes they're
like this is very interesting i've never seen
this color because it was so colorful and it
was like flag on it was saying free to bed um so
right before the game we sang the national anthem
we came in a huddle and there was two gentlemen
from the celtics came to me and said you have to
take your shoes off i was very confused i'm like
what are you talking about he said your shoes have
been getting so much attention we've been getting
so many calls you have to take your shoes off i
was like i cannot believe they're telling me to
take my shoes off it was a perfect moment because
i was just getting ready for my citizenship test
i closed my eyes i was okay there are 27
amendments my first amendment freedom of speech i
was like no i'm not taking my shoes off i was like
i don't care even if i get fined they said we're
not talking about a fight we're talking about
getting banned literally they were threatening me
to get banned just because i was wearing no shoes
and a half time i went back to my locker room
i had thousands of notifications in my phone
i clicked on my manager's text message he said
every celtics game is banned in china rest of
the year i was like that shows my point literally
so and i had one half that was 12 minutes and
12 minutes 24 minutes and one half literally in
24 minutes it took china to ban every satellite's
game on television that's literally censorship and
dictatorship that i was talking about after the
game i was obvious there was a huge media story
and i was like i told my manager i'm not going
to do any media i don't because i didn't want my
teammates to think i'm doing this for attention
so that the next one or two months we did not do
any kind of media um so right after that you know
after the game obviously i was getting called from
obviously nba mbpa the player association they
told me to take your shoes off they're not going
to wear this ever again they were harassing me so
much i talk about the problems that happened in
turkey the last 10 years i did not get one phone
call i talk about the things that are happening
in china my phone was ringing once every hour
me and my managers it got to a point they were
harassing us so much i was like okay i promise you
i'm not going to wear free tibet shoes every game
so the next game i will free uighur shoes they
call me after the game they're like you're a
liar you lied to us you said you're never going
to wear the free tv free tobaccos i was like i
did not have free tibet shoes i wore free eagle
shoes at that point they understand that they're
not going to handle me because they're not going
to make me apologize or take my tweet down or
they're not going to make me say oh i didn't
know enough i was not educated enough i was like
i'm going all day what happened after that what
happened after that we continued to talk about
the problems are happening i started to you know
i i wore uh winnie the pooh shoes i don't know if
you know about winnie the pooh so the the cartoon
we need to pull is banned in china the reason is
people were making fun of the president of
china xi jinping they were telling them that
you look like we need to poop so he literally
banned the whole cartoon in the whole country
and i was like okay let's do something crazy
and then the next one we talk about you know
nike and the next one we talk about hong kong and
taiwan and stop organ harvesting and and stuff and
then i was like well this is becoming a trend and
everyone was asking me okay where can i buy these
shoes where can i do this i was like i'm not gonna
even sell them because i'm literally doing this
just for human rights uh did you receive any
criticism that what you you mentioned earlier that
you were concerned that some people might view
this as you just doing it for attention was there
any indication to you that some people thought
that well the reason i didn't want to do any
kind of interview i didn't want to put the shoes
out there for sale or anything like that because
i didn't want anyone to think that i'm doing this
for attention especially my teammates because i
didn't i didn't care about anyone because i
knew i was you know talking about the right
things i was talking about very uncomfortable
situations that mba never wanted to talk about and
i was like i don't want to say criticism but i
remember my teammates were coming to me one by one
in a locker room and saying you know this is your
last year right you are not going to be able to
get any contract after this they were telling
me listen you attack nike you attack you know
china you won't get you won't play another minute
from this like every uh on this thing ever again
i was like wow they were literally telling
me this is it just because i told you know
about the situation happening in china i'm talk
i expose nike and some other companies and stuff
i was calling out ioc uh olympic committees i was
like well this is the right thing to do i'm just
gonna continue to keep doing what i'm doing so
was there any truth to what they were telling you
of course i mean obviously nba is not going to
come out and say we release them because of that
and february you know try that line i got traded
to not any team but houston rockets that was the
houston rockets was the first the first time that
general manager tweeted something about hong kong
and he put his tweet down and apologize his raka's
was china's team because of yao ming and it was
the first team that went to china and played a
friendly game i believe was against the lakers
so and later on there was an article came out
which we learned that the houston rockets owner
got tied up over 165 million dollar with china
i was like well that clearly shows my point
so you stopped playing in when
was the last time you played
february where are you with the nba
now whereby yeah good question i mean
i'm still working out i'm still obviously before
everything i'm a basketball player and i'm very
thankful for mba because they give me the platform
that i need it and i want it you know so i am very
thankful for mba for giving me this huge platform
worldwide but if they're gonna do something
wrong i'm gonna expose them you know um
where am i with mba right now good question
i don't even know i'm just waiting to hear from
them and i told every team i told my agent to tell
every general manager in nba every owner every
coach i'm ready to play and i want to play
you know so were you you were released from your
contract right is that what happened the last time
i don't so it's not released it's being traded
okay then released okay yeah so i got traded first
okay then i got released okay people say some
people says that you know athletes shouldn't get
into politics well this is not politics there's
a difference between politics and human rights
i've never in my life you can watch my every
interview read all my op-eds or you know
just search on every you know search page on
internet that i have never said we should you
know vote for this guy or not for this guy we
should cheer for this party but not that party i
am right or i'm not left you know and i've never
said anything like that because human rights is
about politics i don't care which side or whoever
you cheer them for whichever party you're part of
you have to care about human rights you know so
if you're talking about human rights yes because i
believe now these these days and you have you know
the media you have the social apps smartphones
and all this you know uh everything that combines
it gives you a huge platform to talk about
whatever you want to talk about it's a amazing
responsibility on your shoulder you know so you
are literally a teacher you can literally teach
and educate our young generation because these
kids are idolizing you and following your
social media every hour maybe so i i believe
athletes or celebrities plays a very important
role in our time and we have to put the right
things out there for our world for our
country so obviously playing basketball
is very important to you i'm pretty sure that
you know making it to the nba is a huge deal
do you have any regrets a lot of people
ask me that question if i have any regrets
i have no regrets because i i mean obviously
i played 11 years in this league and i want
to continue to play another five six whatever
years because i'm healthy i'm 30 i can play you
know with all this technology and the trainers we
have right now can play another six seven years
but this is bigger than basketball this is
bigger than myself and this is being an mba
while we are dribbling the ball on the other side
of the ocean on the other side of the world people
are losing their loved ones losing their lives
and losing their hopes so how can how can you
tell me or how can anyone tell me that hey you
know just stop talking about the problems that
happen around the world just focus on your
game you know um i'm coming from a country
where you know if you say anything you got against
the government you'll be in jail the next day if
you say you you don't even like the president
you know your family might be tortured i remember
my manager's wife stat like one of my posts on
twitter he was in jail for 13 days for 13 days
so i have seen the pain you know i experienced
you know from the first hand my family so
no one can tell me that just stop talking
about all the problems and focus on your game
so this is bigger than basketball and i have no
regrets what's the future is like for you you know
you're starting a i don't know if you want to talk
about your foundation um well i mean right now not
yet no i do yes um well right now we are still
not clear if i'm going to play basketball or not
so but if not then i have to be ready
and prepare for it you know so that's
why i created my foundation as cancer freedom
foundation you know we are focusing on freedom
human rights democracy poverty alleviation
and social harmony around the globe
um so i think with that we will are going to
reach so many other people around the world
and i have seen you know the last six months have
been very lonely obviously after i got released
all my teammates and coaches and the people i
play basketball with for 11 years they're scared
to even send me a text message and say good luck
with your next career because or good luck with
your future because they're scared that if i'm
gonna do an interview or write something that
i might say this guy or that guy was sad he was
supportive of me so they were really scared but
i think other than that i'm just gonna continue
to do what i'm doing you know just bring
awareness about all the dictatorships around
the world so what was the most memorable thing
from your trip to the u.s when you contrasted
it to live into in turkey um well obviously
when i was in turkey you know my family
and my mom was taking care of everything
she was even making my bed uh you know the all
the you know breakfast lunches and everything was
ready and i didn't have to really worry about
anything well i come to america when i was 17
it was definitely a cultural shock because
everything was different the food is different
culture is different religion is different
people are different the language is different
so i was like the first two months i really had
a hard time because all i ate was just burger and
fries i just didn't know what to eat out there
you know i was eating a lot of fast food and
that was the one thing that you know as a middle
eastern the first thing you're now if you were
not educated enough the first thing that was come
to your mind is like america was burger and fries
so my mom was really worried about that i
was just gonna get fat be out of shape and
won't be able to walk but then after two months
i started to you know learn about i was like
i better get used to this i'm this is gonna be
my life from now on um but i think what made me
what amazed me about america was the respect i've
seen i'll tell you a story you know when i was
eight years old i still remember i went downstairs
to play with my you know friends and it was a very
difficult time for turkey and i remember i went
downstairs and my friends were burning american
and israeli flags i was like oh my god this is
crazy and they were telling me to hate america
they were telling me that american people are
evil they were telling me jewish people are devils
i shall hate them no matter what and i'll get
so scared i immediately run upstairs to my mom i
was like mom my friends are burning flags calling
them devils and bad people i should never talk to
them and stuff and i was like what should i do and
my mom is like i'm not gonna tell you what to do
but don't hate anyone before you meet with those
people and so that day i promised my mom and then
nine years late nine years later when i was
17 i came to america and i was very like
nervous because of the things that i have heard in
turkey the reason is because of because of erdogan
whenever he holds a rally because of he want to
get more votes he attacks america he attacks west
he attacks israel and jewish people so there are
so many young generations in turkey growing up
anti-west anti-semitic anti-america anti-israel
anti-west so i came to america for the first time
i landed i was like so scared to even talk to
anyone but then you know people started to you
know respect me people literally took my hand and
went to we we went out to the halal restaurant
they took me to a mosque and they asked me
questions about my culture so they can learn
so they can help me better i was like this
is so beautiful you know and the more people
i met i was like well this is you know just
because of one group of people you cannot blame
the whole country or whole religion you know so
that's what i learned but america gave me my home
america gave me everything i had when i lost my
family when i lost you know my home when i lost
my country when they were calling me a terrorist
or any of the state america opened her arm and
gave me a warm welcome from day one so that was
the one story that i've never you know forgotten
anas thank you so much for talking to reason oh
thank you for having me i appreciate that awesome